HBO's "Game of Thrones" prequel series, "House
of the Dragon" is bringing fans back over 200
years before the events of the main series. With
a new teaser for this prequel recently released,
we've got some questions. For starters, was that
Dragonstone? And what's with that new Stark?
By the time "Game of Thrones" begins, there are no
more folks of Old Valyrian blood left on Westeros.
Daenerys and her brother Viserys are wandering
Essos in exile after the events of Robert's
Rebellion. The new "House of the Dragon" trailer
presents a very different state of affairs, with
more platinum-headed dragonriders skulking around
than you can shake a flaming sword at. What gives?
In the deep Westerosi past, long before the
time of the Mad King Aerys and Robert's fateful
rebellion, there were a lot more Valyrians running
around Westeros — and they weren't all Targaryens,
either. In the mass exodus from Essos after the
Doom of Valyria, two prominent Valyrian families
actually conquered Westeros — the Targaryens and
the Velaryons, the latter of which has died out
by the time "Game of Thrones" begins. At the time
of "House of the Dragon," however, the Velaryons
are still very much on the scene, and will play a
central role in the Targaryen civil war to come.
Marked by their silver hair, expect
the Velaryons to play the Game of
Thrones hard in the new series.
Since there aren't any left by
the time the flagship series starts,
you can imagine how that turns out.
In the new teaser trailer to "House
of The Dragon," audiences witness
some familiar names bending the
knee to King Viserys I Targaryen
"I, Rickard Stark."
"I, Corlys Valaryon."
"I, Corbin Baratheon."
"Thrones" superfans will likely remember that
Eddard Stark's father was named Rickard Stark,
but the Rickard seen in this trailer is alive some
200 years before "Game of Thrones" even starts,
so we're talking a totally different Rick here.
Characters in the world of "Game of Thrones"
tend to name their children after deceased family
members, and the Targaryens are no different.
King Viserys I Targaryen sits upon the Iron
Throne at the start of "House of the Dragon."
Fans who closely recall Season 1 of "Game of
Thrones" will note that Daenarys' older brother
Viserys shares the same distinguished moniker.
This makes King Viserys I Targaryen
Dany and Viserys' distant ancestor,
living some 200 years before any of the
final generation of Targaryens are born.
Targaryen family members have a tendency
to slip into some disturbing behavior,
but it seems Viserys I doesn't fall into that
specific category. The show's official page
describes Viserys I as a kind and decent
king before issuing a stark reminder:
In the world of "Game of Thrones," good
men don't necessarily make for good kings.
"When you play the game of thrones, you
win or you die. There is no middle ground."
Based on the teaser trailer and what we know about
Westerosi history already, "House of the Dragon"
seems to dive into the conflict that arises as
Viserys I grapples with his brother's ambition,
even as he names his first-born child
the heir apparent to the Iron Throne.
In the new trailer for "House of the Dragon," a
familiar and ornate war room in Dragonstone should
have caught the attention of eagle-eyed "Game
of Thrones" fans. This particular meeting spot
in "Game of Thrones" hosts Stannis Baratheon and
the Red Priestess Melisandre for several seasons,
but the heavily fortified city is
left vacant after Stannis' defeat,
and is easily reoccupied by Daenerys Targaryen
after she makes her voyage from Essos.
Fans familiar with "Game of Thrones" lore will
remember that — before Robert's Rebellion — the
fortress of Dragonstone was part of the
Crownlands under the paramount lordship
of the Targaryen kings. By tradition, the
fortress was held by the Targaryen crown prince,
Rhaegar at the time of Robert's Rebellion. That's
why Daenerys "Stormborn" is born on said stormy
island. She was secreted away to that stronghold,
while her brother was out prosecuting Aerys' war,
and fathering Jon Snow with Lyanna
Stark. Stannis is actually the first,
and the last, Baratheon to hold Dragonstone.
So, what military mischief might the dragonriders
be planning around the table this go-around?
Notably, the island of Dragonstone is
adjacent to the island of Driftmark,
seat of House Velaryon. If a conflict is to
break out between the two Old Valyrian houses,
these two islands are likely
to be at the center of it.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite television shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.